welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning the place where
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career today
I'm invited by the consulting firm
structure management partner I will meet
Yan a partner of this firm they prepared
a great set here for us today in Cologne
to talk about what it's like to work in
Consulting what it takes to become
successful even in the first years of
your career trust this will be
insightful if you are interested in
Consulting about any other role as well
so let's get
started thanks for taking the time it's
a pleasure to sit here with you today
can you briefly introduce yourself to
the audience sure I'm Yan I lead our
digital performance and analytics
competence Center and uh previously I
work for an investment bank for a
strategy consulting firm uh I founded a
company a tech startup and and led it to
almost 50 employees and I had different
uh C EXO roles at various companies
sounds like a rich experience indeed we
decided to Focus today's conversation on
the topic of leadership leadership is
for sure a big term many people think
you need to be a partner of a consulting
firm to be able to show leadership or
work in a senior executive role today we
want to focus on how even you in the
first years of your career in consulting
or in corporate roles of course as well
how you can exhibit leadership and we
will structure this along three main
topics client leadership team leadership
and knowledge leadership and we will
later also have the option to talk to
two other Consultants of s SMP a senior
consultant and a Project Lead so looking
forward to that let's start with the
topic of ciance ciance leadership are
there any tips that you can share in
this regard sure uh I think first of all
never start a project without a clear
and aligned project definition if you
don't align on these uh key aspects with
your with your client beforehand you
might run into misunderstandings and
inefficiencies in the project and in the
end disappointments both on the client
but also on the team side and so I
always suggest to really discuss
fundamental aspects like what's the
actual objective of a project what's the
scope what are the tasks and
deliverables of the consulting firms uh
really write things down and make it
explicit uh that that everyone is
aligned on these that very much
resonates with my experience as well
I've seen so many projects go south
because different clients had different
understandings of what the project was
about what the most important things are
even internally this can sometimes be a
nightmare if you have different partners
on the team who have a different
understanding of what the project is
really all about but how exactly do you
do this have any tips on that how you
can actually make this work if you have
a large Board of Directors for example
at the client side so I would suggest to
start uh interviews with each of them
individually and align with a structured
questionnaire on on the key aspects of
the project bring them together and
analyze where where might be different
differences discuss these uh bilaterally
and and then go into the kickoff meeting
when when you have everything aligned
mhm so clear understanding make it also
visible if there are these gaps and then
in the end the concise summary a written
document where you summarize this
absolutely thank you structure
management Partners hiring a significant
number of new Consultants across
positions and locations in Germany if
this is something that is of interest to
you as well feel free to directly reach
out to Yan we will put the link to his
LinkedIn profile in the video
description you can ask him questions on
LinkedIn or also directly send him your
CV if you want to apply Yan with and
share more information with you can you
share a little bit more about what the
typical project ATR tool management
partner looks like sure we're one of the
leading consulting firms in German
middle for topics such as turnaround
transformation and value creation and
German middle for us means companies
with a turnover between 50 million and 2
billion and why should someone apply to
sh management partner there are from my
point of view basically three reasons
first is impact so you need to be
effective in a turnaround situation you
can't just produce slides second is
purpose so we help to uh help struggling
companies in German middle so in the
backbone of the German economy so it's
very fulfilling and the third one is
that you have from the first day on you
have uh exposure to cxos to private
Equity investors to company owners which
is very good for Steep larning curve
makes sense and I can only share that
after announc that I'm doing this
collaboration with Co management partner
I got lots of positive feedback also
from the community if you're interested
to learn more about this feel free to
directly reach out to Yan via LinkedIn
link to his LinkedIn profile in the
video description German language skills
are a requirement to work at shle
management partner you can directly send
your CV to Yan and then Lear more about
the process the next topic you want to
talk about is team leadership how can
you lead your own internal team and how
can you contribute to that even as a
junior your colleague any tips that you
can share in this regard yeah indeed
that's one of the most important aspects
and I would suggest to really look at
the strengths of each team member and
then staff your team uh pretty wisely
and as we all know top management
consulting cases can be very differently
so from uh market analysis to
transformation project or restructuring
cases and the skills you need in each of
these project types to be successful can
be very different so market analysis
would be a lot of number crunching um
restructuring would be focused very much
on on corporate finance and uh
transformation would be focused probably
on on change management and
communication and we all know not
everyone can be perfect in everything
and so as a Project Lead You need to
understand beforehand what are the
strengths experiences of each project
member and then staff them accordingly
yeah that makes a lot of sense from the
Project Lead perspective as a junior who
wants to get staed of course of course
you need to understand also for yourself
how do you set yourself up for success
in the choice of the projects at the
same time you also want to learn right
you want to maybe develop your Excel
skills even if you can't do it yet will
there be mentors on the projects how
does this work yeah that's an
interesting aspect so you could uh build
kind of mentoring teams when you know
that someone for example isn't that good
in Axel but but needs to learn these
skills and you have a project lead who
is really experienced in this so you can
uh uh you can bring them both together
and and plan some time for for really
ramping this this new colleague up in in
this regard yeah makes sense and this is
I think also something that can be
addressed in the team kickoff this at
least something what we often did I
assume you work with similar processes
how does this work at S&P yeah
definitely take your time at the
beginning of a project and sit together
as a team and discuss pretty frankly
what are each team members strength what
are the experiences and what are the
expectations and what what does everyone
needs or or wants to learn at this
project and then to find a project
structure that uh yeah is optimal for
for this setup then makes sense from my
point of view the project success is
never determined by the performance of
one single individual but from the group
itself therefore it's highly important
for me that we don't have any hidden
agenda within the team and that we
communicate directly with each other
especially when we Face problems or
challenges in a team besides
professional competences it is also
important to take into account the
different working habits each team
member
has professionals and Consulting our
knowledge workers of course in the end
so it's all about knowledge you need to
lead in this knowledge area as well any
tips that you can share in this regard
yeah extremely important point and I
think the most important thing or one of
the most important things you can learn
in Consulting is structuring problems
structuring solutions and you really
need this because you are thrown into
different situations a new company uh
with a in a new market and and
completely new new problems right every
every project is is is something new and
so really need to structure yourself
structure the topic and then Define the
right hypothesis to work efficiently on
on the right topics indeed and in
business people use the term the VOA
world right volatility uncertainty
complexity ambiguity this is the
situation that you are faced as a
manager and being able to structure the
issues in a systematic way with tools
such as hypothesis based problem solving
issue trees the Mei principle and so on
that you learn in Consulting is
definitely very helpful also outside of
your roles in Consulting any tips on how
you can develop these types of skills oh
yeah I really recommend to to practice
it with friends or with colleagues and
just just take a topic and try to
structure it and then get challenged by
your friend or your colleague and you
really find out that things like misas
sound pretty easy in the beginning and
when you try to apply it it's it's
really good to practice and I think uh
learning curve is extremely steep in
this topic in the first years of
Consulting that's exactly why it's so
exciting definitely personal branding is
important from my own experience I've
witnessed that you can have a successful
career whether you're a specialist or
more an allrounder moreover along your
career path you will find and identify
new fields of interest that attract your
attention I highly encourage everyone to
follow one's intuition and invest in
your education and to round this off I
prepared a special treat here for you
and this is community questions so
yesterday on Instagram I asked the
community what questions they might have
for a Consulting partner and the first
is the following what makes candidates
stand out in partner interviews and for
the uninitiated partner interviews are
interviews that you have usually at the
end of the process with the partner of
the consulting firm any tips that you
can share in this regard sure um the
partner interview is all about
personality and cultural fit whereas in
the first interviews you've proven
already your analytical skills and a lot
of other things so the partner real
looks do you fit into the team because
we all know Consulting teams uh need to
work on high time pressure often a very
challenging task and so it's it's really
important that you have a good team fit
and that's what the partner looks at
fully agree the atmosphere and the team
is the most important thing and I trust
this is what you will check for yeah
next question and this is an interesting
one is visibility more important than
actual performance so on my channel I
talk a lot about visibility how
important it is also to be visible in an
organization any insights you can share
in this regard both are important from
from my experience at S&P I would say we
have a clear focus on client
satisfaction and the client
recommendation rate which is at at 98%
so we do everything that the client is
happy and this is priority number one
but at the same time it's also important
to help develop the firm for example we
have an artificial intelligence task for
us where you can uh bring in your ideas
internally we have a recruiting team we
have different competent centers and so
I think it in the end it's a good
balance uh between project performance
and also internal visibility that makes
you successful what makes shour
management partner stand out and why
should one start a career at shour
management partner Yan trust do you have
a perspective on that Yes actually we
are pretty unique in the Consulting word
usually Consulting is all about sales
right we consciously choose another way
and look at it from a systemic
perspective so we really focus only on
client recommendation rate so how many
of our clients are happy with with the
work we we did for them and so this
attracts different kind of people than
other consulting firms and you can see
this when you look look at for example
average staff retention rate so people
are uh on average 4 and a half years at
at our firm and when you look at kununu
at the last two or three years you see
we get a score of 4.6 to 4.9 and 100%
recommendation rate from from employees
so this shows that we are pretty unique
in in this regard these are quite
impressive numbers thank
you now I'd love to hear from you what
is your thought on the top topics that
we discussed I definitely learned a
couple of new things as well feel free
to ask your questions in the comments
the S&P team will monitor the comment
section and come back to you if you took
any value out of this video at all
please like And subscribe to stay up to
date on my content my name is Hinrich I
release weekly videos here on the
channel big thanks to all the members of
from learning as well see you again next
week and
byebye